were there any red flags that you saw
today
Pearl did you watch it behind scene hold
up hold up
what about this one
yo
how did the final round go
so
MTR what's up how are your dates today
you put you put an Eclectic group in
front of me Pearl I don't know where you
got them from but they was a collectic
people together here we don't like to
tear men and women apart like we're
often accused of we bring them together
we bring them together thanks now tell
me were there any red flags that you saw
today
Pearl
um were you watching behind scene I want
to hear this from your point of view
don't let me influence you you got me
hooked up with a conspiracy theorists
number one okay didn't sound like she
was looking for a man to be honest with
you she wasn't looking for a man I
understand that now I feel like I was a
pawn I think she was looking for a man
but a man that's gonna kill a cow
I'm not killing cattle cattle cows cows
they're cute okay um then you also set
me up with a single mother times two
um two different
children
Pearl you know hold up you know if I
watch your content Pearl okay I put this
together in 48 hours
she was a sweetheart though I felt like
you guys had some chemistry we
definitely had some chemistry so you
know could the chemistry get you past
the children
okay
girl okay you know
Pearl okay you know that was my bad that
was my she brought you a crystal
every time I picked this up I started to
feel cooler about the world you know
what I'm saying like I think it's
actually working you know so I did the
best I could
who's in charge of the budget here it's
rough out there for the guys
modern modern it's like I have the men
ready where are the women where are the
women you know listen you know what's so
crazy is that they'll complain about
their options right but then like you
know I I feel you're here I think that
I'm a good you know what I mean a good
option a good candidate a good candidate
you know what I mean I got I got some
things about me that I think most women
would like and that was difficult but
you can't kill a cow I I no that's
that's like not my thing I mean if it
was the end of the world right and there
was no supermarkets I'd have to do what
I'd have to do but like right now like
nah like we can go to you know Target
and go pick up some sirloin yeah
well try to try to be more masculine
next time
I'll work on it what other red flags
were there so the conspiracy theorists
yeah was
um the two baby daddies okay yeah
anything else
um
I'm trying to think
uh anything else that was a red flag
um
uh the first conversation that I had
with the attorney would I be concerned
with is a degree of conditional
femininity
because it sounded like you know she's
on a growth path and a growth trajectory
and um at being 33 I believe she was 33
years old
and then understanding that at 28 she
was a completely different person from a
personality perspective is a bit
worrisome
so I don't know if that'd be a red flag
so much as a key indicator that she
might go back right right when reverted
right like it makes me think like is
there a mask there that she's putting up
and at the point where her back's up
against the wall she reverts back into
Modern Woman ideology
see mm-hmm
anything else what about what about
Melanie Mel yeah look at you guys you
know we always talk about this is what I
don't understand in the manosphere okay
okay men and women can't be friends
no so you guys aren't friends we're busy
we're business friends so
but men and women can't truly be friends
correct I'm with you so you know you
guys could work in the same industry she
said she'd give up her YouTube channel
to support you
it seems like a match made in heaven so
you think no I'm asking I'm asking why
not well
um here's the thing me Mel and I talked
about it and I think it's specific to
her having uh two children
um it's something that I probably you
know I'd take a look at and you know
it's not something that I would
optimally look at
as a potential mate yeah
that'll do it ladies yeah that will
definitely do it you know but she's
divorced you know she gave it a shot
didn't work out for whatever reason we
actually didn't get to in the
conversation Why didn't it work out
but when I consider
um that cross the Bear in uh comparison
to other young ready and willing
participants you know also too I forgot
that attempt in this one one of the
young ladies was a pole dancer I forgot
about this one and then I mean maybe it
was for her Fitness you know listen no
no I went on the Instagram I want to
bring her back up here because she was
but I want to bring about back up up
here because I want to ask him more
questions about the Instagram because I
I went back on it and I saw her clitoris
muscle on her Instagram and I wanted to
ask her future questions regarding that
well out of this
lovely group of women that we have put
together today you know
um what
you got a choice to make I brought you I
brought you five women today yes I need
you to pick your final two the final two
you show not three I think two was
better because it's like yeah all right
you really want a third
let's let's go through it real quick no
so so so first and foremost yo shout out
to shout out to all the lovely young
ladies that took the opportunity to come
down here and to talk with me and the
thing is is that you know I don't know
how many of them have seen my channel
before that but to come down here and
see on my channel and let your life you
know let me be let me be able to ask you
whatever questions I want that takes a
certain degree of emotional stability
that I give you credit for all right
that's the first thing second thing is
Mel and I are business associates so she
will not be moving on to the next round
now you already know I got a lot of love
for you all right you super cool but you
will not move on to the next round all
right that's the homie though okay next
um in terms of who's moving on the top
two or the top three I would say I want
to ask more questions to dania
I want to ask more questions to
Lauren I think our name is Lauren is
that the law yeah yeah I want to ask
more questions to Lauren all right so
Donya and Lauren and I'm trying to think
if there's any others definitely not the
activists
um I thought that was going well in the
beginning I thought it was to you she
judged me off of many things I feel like
the type of guy that she's looking for
is
.0001 of man and I wish I luck on on on
her you know whichever she's looking for
it's a very small percent of men that
what she's looking for but you know I
should farmer country
wherever the farmers are in England yeah
but you say country she she will
completely not go to the entire country
United States of America
that's what she said
so she's got to go to a country where
you know it's not laws that make it yeah
maybe there's so anyways okay so no no
no conspiracy theorists no conspiracy
I'm trying to think all the others
um whom I'm missing she's kind of
spitting facts
Hey listen this laughing it was a lot of
things that that she was saying but you
know it's just too much for me I was
like spitting facts anyways sorry
continue
um yeah I think I think those two unless
I'm forgetting anybody okay
so the lawyer yeah
and the pole dancer
it's crazy how we have the complete
opposites of each other I think one
thing my mind I'm thinking of myself do
I do I want to um find like a
long-lasting relationship or don't want
to have fun for the evening
demon time MTR
or delayed gratification MTR well let's
find out I'm gonna go grab the ladies
for you
um I wish you luck in your quest for
Love Is It Love at this point uh-oh I
mean
anyways
Pearl bring the contestants okay
so you're back I'm back for round two
round two did you think he was gonna put
my hand you put your hands on the table
like you want to hold my hands did you
think you was gonna get back for round
two I was hopeful I wasn't sure you
wasn't sure what are the things that you
saw based off of the conversations I had
with the other young women that would
have told you or made you a little bit
fearful that you wouldn't have gotten
invited back
um I mean fearful nothing but I would
say
um I think they were cute flirty you
know you got to give honest to that they
were very pretty girls
um about something different very
different for me so I think it boils
down to what you are really looking for
and interested in at the end because we
all were very different in our own
rights so
that's what's up so let me also ask you
because I don't know if I asked this
really like what are the type of things
you like to do for fun at my at my hobby
so
um I am
how many states in all countries you've
been to
the count I've never counted actually
but I've been I would say a minimum of
like
15 20 somewhere like that I've been a
lot of places I've started traveling
when I was told States or countries
countries countries yeah okay I started
traveling when I was 12. my um Dad
introduced me to it so top two spots
Portugal and this is Stateside but San
Diego is my favorite place in the states
yeah I haven't been I haven't been
either yet really yeah I've Been to
Spain I've been in Barcelona Portugal
yeah got another Portugal and you know
Portugal is not saying it's like right
next door to it though I'm very familiar
I'm very familiar that it's not Spain
but in terms of
um geography it's right next to it yeah
it was like very similar but very
different culture different language
yeah but I love Portugal you got to go
to Portugal yeah that's number one San
Diego number two that's what's up yeah
I'm in there yeah yeah it apparently has
the best weather in the world
perfect all the time um and then another
happy I love poker
I like to play poker um I'm good at it
because people are like the female I'm
like chatty and friendly so they think I
don't know what I'm doing it means
you're a good liar no I'm honest I'm
actually like I get a little nervous
when you gotta Bluff and do all the
other stuff but you can't be good at
poker and not be a good liar I disagree
but see this is where this hold up hold
up like on the play flag on the flag on
the planet review okay so you can't
drink it so you don't agree that you can
be a good liar and a good because here's
the thing is you know when I think about
what I remember you was the first one
that we did a um a date about the first
thing that I remember is it there seems
to be a difference in who you were at 28
versus who you are at 33 is it
it seems to be a difference so in my
mind I'm like okay is this actually her
that's going on this feminine this
feminine Journey
or is this a facade
is this who she's now created in order
to hit her and go and and result it's
kind of like if you go to a car
dealership right like and there's the
car over there with the water damage
with you know they had the pet stains
and dander within it right right
the engine that was blown up but they
just put a Fresh coat of paint on that
you know posted some of the things
within it but I got all of the baggage
underneath that is bad yeah I guess
within that knowing that you're a good
liar because you're a good poker player
I think poker is about reading people
and knowing what's that hand like oh I
got this do I really think somebody else
could really compete with this and go
with it right it's reading people
understanding people I wouldn't qualify
it as a lying per se right bet on
yourself right even when you don't feel
like showing up some days or you don't
feel like it the Imposter syndrome you
know really what you have and can I see
this through and go all the way I'm
gonna bet on myself 100 at any day right
so that's what poker is to me
what's your self-care activities Oh I
love the spot and I liked um facials I
do a whole little steaming at home
that's a bad joke there I'm gonna
or not saying
facials the spa
uh-oh Spas facials um traveling honestly
it's a lot of self-care so whenever I'm
traveling I always am working obviously
but I make sure to build in days where I
have self-care when I can take time for
myself
um turning my phone off honestly just
disconnecting from the world I like
reading I read a lot of books um so
what's the last book that she read
Atomic habits
speaking of changing and being something
different for the side I don't want to
ignore your question we could pivot back
into that yeah so I think people have a
character right there are
characteristics that people have and
then there are like habits and so I
would say habits are things that we
learn over time and that we most of the
time when you have bad habits they're
hard to change but my character and who
I am characteristically can always be
built upon it can always be developed so
who I am as a person has not changed I
just have allowed myself to evolve and
to get better Lauren has always been
caring Lauren has always been genuine
Lauren has always been very direct and
very straightforward but how I delivered
it was assertive it was aggressive it
was contentious contentious even right
but Lauren isn't contentious anymore I'm
so direct I'm so honest I'm so loving
but how I turn how I present those
things now is what has changed but the
car is still the car right I'm still the
same person and I honestly can say my
friends and my family can rest of that
still my very much a work in progress
too I'm not perfect I have not reached
an attainable thing and I don't think
that's something I'm going to reach just
because I'm married and I have kids now
right I always want to be improving I
always want to get better and that comes
with the feedback from my husband
marriage is a mirror he's going to look
at me and be like yeah I know you did a
lot of work boo but um
so so so the anal so the analogy is is
that you know as a car is you know more
weathered or has more baggage when that
happens you know they might cover the
different things in order to be able to
sell it so the idea is is that you know
are you covering things to be able to
sell a particular product because as a
as a man today you know that
rationalizes my free time my space my
purpose right other things that I could
be doing from an entertainment
perspective within my life in order to
change these different things the
business case of the Modern Woman today
or just use it specifically needs to be
of one of which makes sense to give me
an Roi that's better than all of these
things combined right but if what this
equation is is such that it is a lemon
it is a car with extreme baggage then
I'm gonna get tricked and I just don't
want to get tricked at the end of the
day you know
okay so that's that's
um we'll have habits that they've
gathered over life and their environment
exposure and things like that and so
character-wise I'm still the same person
right my core motto of a car if you will
um is the same it has not changed right
so I'm still caring I'm so honest I'm
still
um loving however the way I deliver
those things I'm no longer aggressive
I'm no longer assertive I'm no longer
contentious those are the things I've
been working on not to change myself so
we're not trying to like catfish nobody
from a personality standpoint but we've
been trying to improve on that which I
think is something people should
continuously be improving on over time
right as I become a wife if I become a
mother those things are going to require
different things out of me that as a
core person I'm the same but they help
me evolve and develop more and go deeper
into those areas of life so
characteristically I am just evolving
and adding to and becoming a better
person versus oh this is just a habit
that I'm gonna switch up or change out
or do any things like that and I have
character witnesses that could be speak
to that right you know the whole legal
name if you're back in but my family and
friends who have been along this journey
and process with me
um both providing feedback and just
observing can really say like you are
getting better in this or even providing
more feedback like we still need to work
on this and my husband's going to
provide feedback right as a mirror he's
going to be able to look and say yeah I
know you've been working on this book
but
work on this a little bit more or do
that can I ask you a question are you
familiar with the slap heard around the
world
no Will Smith
oh Chris Rock yes what's your thoughts
regarding that situation was he right or
was he wrong
explain why I think once again has his
character to want to defend his wife
positioning was a hundred percent on
point right but the delivery of it right
as a man as a leader you have to be
mindful of the positions that you put us
in with that and so am I back in my bed
a hundred percent right like
um it is what it is well we got to deal
with it and we go we're gonna work it
out from here but the delivery to do
that on a public thing I just I I don't
think that that was the right delivery
method for it but how should you have
handled it you say
um I yeah he could even get on stage
still and said you know what Chris
you're not gonna come for my wife this
way et cetera et cetera we're gonna
handle this off stage right
a public display is nothing would have
been wrong with that but to go and
assault another man on public camera in
front of millions of people
um was not the best look especially in
America where men are already seen and
so aggressive right we're in the middle
of all the rights with police brutality
right and you of a man of influence
having this platform was that the real
best delivery method to defend your wife
in that moment I love the protection but
that was not the best way to go about
delivering it absolutely not I
understand do you think that you are a
better option for a man at 33 or 23.
for me personally 33 because maturity
the things that I've gone through the
things that I've gleaned and I've
learned I do understand for a man
um wanting children and things like that
the age might come into play for that
but we live in America and we can have
kids and well into our 40s that's not
the goal by any means but I definitely
think I am more characterized ready in
position especially having friends who
got married at 20 they're divorced now
right looking to remarry
character-wise I'm more of a better
option now than I was at 23. what other
questions do you have for me so what is
your ideal first date
ideal first date well it's not this
it's not it's not here in front of the
cameras or nothing like that but you
know ideally
um let's say that I met you and I know
you're from the hole in the wall like I
would appreciate
like a coffee date something easy a walk
in a park that's if I didn't know you
from a hole in the wall but let's say
like we established some type of
foundation you know we video chatted
multiple times right we called each
other multiple times like there's been
like text threads and stuff like that
then ideally I would want to do
something to see you much more in your
natural state I don't want to take you
somewhere where you got to feel like
you're like like you gotta be someone
something that you're not so what I
probably do is try to ask like what are
the things that you're you know into and
then I would try to coordinate something
around what it is that you're into like
so if you said like I'm into
I don't know
um you know uh you know you watch like
funny videos on YouTube or something
like that maybe I'll go out and like get
something like a comedy show
right because like
um you know there's a correlation
between watching entertainment on TV and
then watching it within real life right
so then you know so it's something that
you would
um think was dope so I probably
coordinated around something that she is
just so I can see her in her natural
state when she feels uh most comfortable
and then probably for the second one I'd
do something that I want to do in my in
my natural state and I think of the two
I'd be able to like really diagnose or
digest who she is as a person to
determine if she's going to be a
well-formed fit within my life I'm very
excited seeing if even her and her true
element is a good fit for you right so
that's another question for you what's
up so you are this Grand influencer on
YouTube you have a pretty big platform I
want to say Grand but yeah I'm gonna
her in and so with that you know
there's definitely the balancing of life
that has to happen right with the two so
how do you
um
separate the Persona that you have to
show up on when you are in that world
and like in your regular life and
honestly how do you help others do the
same for you because some people can
meet you I didn't I didn't know you
before in that light right but people
who do know you before their light and
they meet you and that's the lens that
they see you in how do you help them
navigate really getting to know the real
MTR
um how do I get to navigate you know I
don't think that my off-camera
personality is much different than my
own camera personality I mean there's
certain things I do from like an
entertainment perspective
um but I just have a conversation
you know what I mean like I don't know
have you seen it in my content yes
little clips of it actually do you think
I found that out I didn't know that but
then I was like oh people have sent me
your stuff and it was you okay yeah oh
so people have sent you sent me yes I've
never watched your YouTube or anything
like that but my friends have sent me
clips of your stuff giving reviews or
your feedback on
um dating scenarios and things like that
so based off of the things that you have
seen do you think it's a lot different
than what you've seen either here or
like you know behind scenes
not much no I think you're very honest
direct
um yeah nothing would be similar but you
know people people they most so helping
them navigate when people see you and
they're like oh my God it's you and the
fandom of it right do you get a lot of
that
yeah see and so how do you I mean it's
weird for me is it a turn off
um
women don't recognize me
it's men that recognize me So when you
say turn off
um it doesn't apply got you yeah because
most of my audience is men got you um
and like men in relationships they might
send it to their girl and then the girl
generally doesn't like me sit down and
watch me so so women are not foreign
yeah and I can support you in your
efforts over there you know I would love
to come
along with me girl of course I will I
say passport ready I just you know make
sure that you have your water and the
things that you need you're gonna add
some stamps to your past I got you yes
no would you be willing to learn sure do
not right I do I'm yeah unfortunately I
learned in law school yeah I do I do
know how to write yes what do you need
I'll ask you all these questions that I
probably would never want want you to be
a part of to be honest and real talk
though I would say that yes I would
learn editing for you but realistically
for us both it will probably be a better
option for me to go find somebody to
edit for you and to Outsource that for
you but I could take on the task of
Outsourcing it for you realistically it
just would be better could I learn sure
am I gonna be good that's another
question so yeah you know a quick little
fix here you go boo but long term
if you want to drift I got you got your
bag we ride over here but I'ma say we're
gonna need you to you're going long term
we want you to have somebody stable that
we could just sing things I got some
connections for that too
you're cool thank you no I I no no I I
like your swag I like the things that
you talk about and I think that you've
worked uh well within yourself to
understand certain things that would be
very important to a guy I have value
right like how do you add value to him
not just to make things earlier no say
like things easier not earlier but yeah
honestly that's that's that's my goal
and what I've learned I have like I told
you I have brothers
um and they I've seen them go through
really really bad relationships and I've
always looked at those relationships and
be like even if you're not gonna be
together why you just can't make this
easier for him he's not a bad man like
he is the father of your kids whatever
the scenario would be like why are we
here and doesn't that make your life
hard why do you want to have this hard
life I don't understand it so and that's
why I actually buy self-care activities
because I often find it hard to make
time for self-care activities so like
when I think about
um a woman being a part of what it is
that I'm building or just being a part
of my space it's like you know how can
she remind me to do things to continue
to keep my cup runneth over and let me
get you a facial can I give you a facial
okay what is a facial a facial really so
it's just
a cleansing process for this for the
skin it's a deep cleanser I do them at
least two to three times so you just
wash your face extra hard no no no no
not hard we want to be gentle with the
skin
[Music]
oh the red light came on that means we
gotta ask the Red Light Special
questions okay the light matches your
dress you know because
I stay now you just glow
do you like to work out
okay what type of exercises do you do
you know you got to do the booty
exercise
lunges hit thrusts all of that with the
bar you got to get the belt in probably
I'm 16
no you not yes I'm yes I am standard
we're the same height you got Hillsong I
don't have Hills on at the moment wait
stand up stand up they gonna catch us on
camera instead of hot talk come on
come on no hold up
they're gonna look at the uh
they say the No No you're not oh yeah
you are six two
I must be six three then you still got
me he said I got you by a little bit
yeah
but yeah you gotta do all the booty
exercises and the core exercises you got
to make sure you have strong hips for
birth giving you know yeah in the strong
core so it's not back right we gotta
yeah because you can't let the core just
you know uh just just become a kangaroo
pouch that's not that's nice
that's not sexy time's up
absolute pleasure to make your
acquaintance likewise my darling all
right yes yes all right all right
welcome back hi how you doing I'm good
did you expect to be called back I did I
did you did that must mean that you
thought we super connected
with some guys we had a little something
something going on that's what's up
we're here back I wanted to find out a
lot more information okay all right now
I went on the Instagram and I had more
questions okay I'm gonna pull up some
things right here okay because when we
talked about you know if I asked you to
get off of it you pretty much said no
like you said like you know there's a
lot of different opportunities available
however one of the things that I think
through within
um dating a young woman is that
um I look at and see kind of her past as
well as you generally look at who I am
as a man in my future going into
the future right
um so let's say I want to go through
because the first couple that I went
through I was like oh there's some
dope ass photos up here but I did see
um how do you feel about that one
do you know what I think the woman's
body is Art and a lot of the sheets that
I do work on I'm paid for
um oh she got paid for this one yeah
yeah okay you might tell me how much
I'm not gonna say how much okay I don't
discuss my income
that's so that's fine so like let's say
like let's say you made let's say on a
good sale let's say make a thousand
dollars for this let's say on a good
side which I think for a photography
shoe is probably decent right let's say
you made a thousand for this but you
have the opportunity to date a guy that
you know with his you know time
attention assets you're gonna make way
more than a thousand per month in value
um but he's asking you to remove I
understand that photo I would happily
take that down you would happily take
down that one down
um
that's a good one right there I'ma like
that one
I feel like I should be screen recording
this one so you can just get the file
just raise them up let's raise it up all
right I'm gonna raise it up
this is public by the way this is not
private so this is the one
um what you see right here is a
delectable body with the mammary glands
crossed out with the touch of her finger
in the editing software
and then I kept on scrolling that's cool
that I like that one right there
I like that one you you look I would say
like this you look like a sophisticated
Savage right here
yes or no what you think I guess so yeah
I get down I see a bathing suit photo it
is what it is again decent advertisement
all right
what about this one if I was like y'all
too much
that was actually a Content trip abroad
so if I didn't get paid for that so I'm
happy happy to take that down okay
and then you probably you might have to
probably blur this one out as well I saw
this one you look like you're in
um Venice I am you're in Venice yeah
yeah you're a Venice on this one now you
have on lingerie
and you your clit's pierced
no no that's not my if you know
anything about female anatomy what is it
Michael is not going to be halfway up
well here's the thing is that like this
what is that labia no I don't have my
flat pears
at all no that there's a there's a shiny
thing there yeah there's a piercing but
it's not my what what's pierced
it's Dakota Christina
quarter Christine Christina piercing
doesn't give any sexual pleasure doesn't
do anything
literally so it's just on your skin like
on your hip bone no
no where where I'm confused like it's
above like you know I I can use the
scientific term but I don't know like
the bottom hip
the one's pubis
what the hell is the months you guys
know like the fatty bit on the top okay
like on the front so it's not like
anything like down there like it doesn't
change anything or
all right so you're so so so so so you
got the the go Zone which is the the
clip above that you have the clitoral
hood and above that you got the fatty
bit
it's on the fatty bit yeah
wow
what made you want to get that one
um I had it for quite a while actually
me I've always been like
um
I've quite enjoyed my piercings but I'm
not a big fan of facial piercings you
see I don't have anything yeah I have my
ears pierced but I don't really wear
earrings do you like pain
[Music]
um
I wouldn't say I like I love it but I
just like I don't mind it do you
um are you like BDSM
um I've never tried any of that so I
can't really say
got it yeah so so just piercings is what
you're about
I do like piercing when I was younger
I've taken a lot of them out now I don't
actually have many piercings anymore but
well I guess is it tough to have them in
um when you're pole dancing no I just
kind of throughout them and just
and just say okay cool cool cool cool no
that's that's uh listen it's um I'm not
I'm not a Pearson's got more of a tattoo
guy yeah
yeah I have a I have a decent amount of
tattoos sometimes yeah
they all got meetings sometimes I walk
by the mirror and I'm like okay that's
that's enough
that's enough definitely
almost I just want yeah I want them do
you have tattoos I have a tattoo on my
spine yeah I promise Arabic yeah it says
be the energy you want to attract that's
what's up and I also have a turtle on my
hip here yeah um that was my first solo
trip
um I traveled to Mexico I traveled
around Mexico and
um it was a very eye-opening experience
a lot about myself and I remember going
into this um it was like a zoo kind of
thing
but um I started with Turtles as well in
the sea but there was just this giant
turtle it was massive like I have never
seen anything like it and I was like
that's amazing uh I wanted it tattooed
on me as a memory of my
trip so okay what type of guy are you
looking for
um
I think in a relationship I just want a
guy to be authentic I just wanted to be
himself
um someone who can protect me
just the basic book standard I guess
would you what'd you feel about coming
to America I would come to America I
don't want to raise my children in the
UK really especially in London I think
the attitude is horrible when you want
to have children but you say you're 22
I'm 22 yeah
um before I'm 30 but I do want to make
sure that I have a have a stable
environment to raise my children in
I don't want them to grow up having to
struggle or like
go through certain things so the um the
Instagram in conjunction with the pole
dancing I think to myself party girl
Port parties I never go out so you're an
introverted
pole dancing
piercing loving there seems to be a lot
of dichotomy like they're saying a lot
of differences like why I'm trying to
it's hard for me to nail what's going on
here the last time I went to the club
was January last year
so I haven't been to the club in over a
year I'm so confused you you you I I I
love my own company I really do I spend
a lot of time by myself I have a
collection of books like to read I'm
very
it's because I like to hold I put off
for Fitness this makes me stronger
there's something about it right like I
don't know if the cameras are on or
something like that and I feel like I
have a lot more leverage if the cameras
were not on because I'd ask certain
questions in order to I feel like I
don't know who you are because you're so
all over the place so I guess if you
would if you were to describe who you
are like what what would that be a
foodie okay I love food
um I am I can be quite introverted
I can come out of my shower certain
environments bring me out of my shell
um I used to be really really really shy
like wouldn't speak to anyone
severe like social anxiety but
definitely in the last couple years I
started pushing myself and forcing
myself to go into situations that I
might not have done before for example
even coming on this podcast going abroad
and shooting traveling by myself going
halfway across the world on my own and
it's really taught me a lot about myself
and I feel like speaking more of a
confident person
in general but yeah I love food a lot I
can talk about food forever
so have you thought about doing like a
food Instagram everyone tells me this
but I don't know my main I do want to
start a business obviously I'm trained I
trained as a dental nurse so I can get
my medical license so then I could open
an Aesthetics business I know it's a bit
different in the US you have to be a
registered nurse or a doctor I believe
but um yeah so I want to have an
Aesthetics business hopefully open like
a chain I do want it to be a chain but
if I'm thinking like way way way ahead
but um
do you think that the um things that you
post from like a social media
perspective would deter or derail
certain men from morning to date you
yeah 100
but you're willing to deal with those
consequences yeah
yeah okay and they'll do those
consequences right like
um let's say that you will to look back
on your life decisions in life let's say
you make it to 40 and you still single
would you look back on that decision to
display yourself like that and have
regret
I'm not someone that lives with regret I
think in life you only regret the things
that you don't do and I'm not telling
people to go out there and like put
their body on the internet and do all of
these things but to take opportunity
if you there's so many opportunities
that have been thrown at me in the past
and I haven't taken them just because
I've been shy and then it's like wow if
I took them then where would I be today
kind of thing but um yeah I'm not
someone that lives with regret you can
change you can learn from something
everything in life is a blessing or a
lesson
so
I live by that
I'm surprised you don't have an only
fans
so that's okay I feel like you can you
could you can monetize the you the pole
dance and stuff with instructional
tutorials and stuff like that bahana
only fans as well so you've never
thought about doing a patreon
don't want to produce that yeah so yeah
you don't want to project that that type
of
brand
yeah that's what I respect it though
yeah everyone do you have any questions
for me
um yeah I do actually yeah so what's
your situation with your family like are
you close to your families you have any
siblings yeah I'm close to my family I
um I was raised an only child but I
found out when I was in college that I
had a sister
and that essentially my family was a
victim of paternity fraud where um the
mother of my sister put the paternity on
someone that was not her father
okay so my father
was her father but he didn't know
um and it's actually one of the things
that I often promote on my channel is
that I think paternity testing should be
an obligation or at Birth
I think 100 of people should be
paternity tested
I agree to an extent obviously I think
that if there's a level of trust within
each other then I don't think
you know you should go into a good faith
I think
yeah but you know faith without works is
often dead and I think you know
sometimes you gotta work it with the
data
[Music]
but but I think that um yeah it's sort
of faith without works is dead and I
think that um you know there's a lot of
um destruction that can happen in a
family if someone just decides not to be
truthful regarding
paternity and I mean it happens more
often than what we like to it's just a
consequence of you know
just being born you know and the
consequence of not holding those
accountable that can just lie it's
unfortunate you know so
it is what it is
your sister
yeah I mean as close as we can't we
don't live in the same state and
um you know but every time that I go
back home yeah we're always like you
know doing dinner or stuff like that I
became an uncle overnight
you know oh she's got kids oh my gosh
yeah she's got a 30 year old and like a
27 year old yeah like out of nowhere
yeah super grown that was an uncle out
of nowhere
you know I mean look like we got the red
light right now
any other um
what did you do last night like what do
you normally do you go out no I was here
last night
what
oh that's right you were
yeah yeah
okay so you was realizing you didn't go
out after no I'm at home I need my bed
damn son you an introvert introvert well
it was like 3am
fill it I feel it cool so what we gonna
go out on the next day if if I do select
you we're like where would you want to
go
uh someone with an activist
activity but I just think it's a bit
boring
um yeah something fun maybe like
even a picnic or something I think
picnic's good
nice scenery what if I asked you to make
the meal
to make the meal
I do that I love cooking so try to pick
me
boom done set
yeah
cool
all right all right so MTR
how did the final round go
ES
I'll be honest with you Pearl
been difficult
it's been because they were such good
here's the thing bro I've been watching
your channel you know I like I I love
your content and I'm like I'm going to
Pearl's Channel I'm really gonna find
and uh you know there's there's some
there's some obvious things here that
you know makes me just want to select
myself at the end of the day
just put me above me just continue to
create continue with the business
continue on doing me and makes you
want to just do me even more this is
what modern meant today or goddamnation
just the options it's just like come on
shut hold up the top three let's hold up
what's going on real quick
of the top three okay I called back the
young lady with the two kids and I did
that because I wanted to find out more
information
regarding her mindset the way that she
thought about things you know because I
think it is important to tease out these
conversations which seem to because
here's a thing like you know I think
that you know in having a kid it's sort
of like getting a face tattoo in a sense
that it's something that you just can't
remove
right unless you you know there's some
extreme things that you do right so
within that you know how is it is dating
is for you right now you know and at the
same time an understanding that she you
know have vibed with her you understand
so I think it was important to have an
additional conversation with that with
her as well
um then there's the lawyer
um and actually we had a really dope
conversation but I think like of the
contestants
um she is a
um a great pick
um I'm still a little bit concerned
about the transition of the last four to
five years and then also typically I
date younger than 30.
so that's it for that
um so I think of the choices I'd maybe
probably give her the the W
um and then the last one was the
young lady with the pole dancing
Instagram
and you know just like I tell the
fellows on the channel is that like you
know you got to look at that particular
past to try to like understand and even
like kind of the awkwardness of the
conversation of determining hey is that
a piercing on the innards or is that a
piercing on the under innards you know
what I'm saying or the over innards you
know what I mean that could be a tough
first date question tomato tomato right
it's still it's still within the nether
regions of hell right so I think that um
I don't know you you gave me some monkey
wrenches here to deal with and I don't
know who do you think I was gonna pick
Pearl
the climate activists or not I honestly
thought that was that was she was gonna
win coming okay because where's the tape
I didn't know about that I didn't know
about the covet stuff okay she came on
she came on a show talked about some
traditional value she was young she
believed body count mattered I was like
she doesn't she seems like proper so I
was like here's something come on young
lady come come now I see where the baby
mama that probably wasn't the best match
but I was like you never know it's tough
out there for guys let me tell you as a
as the new Matchmaker I could see where
my skill set could improve
listen we're gonna work on your skill
set ability within matchmaking okay at
the same time you know I thought the one
that you know the had a lot of like
conspiracy theories here's the thing is
that like I'd be more than willing to
hear like more when she said she could
probably taught me a bunch of different
things and I'm not discounting that but
I would say initially in meeting I was
just kind of like okay what's going on
here are you here to talk about your
platform or are you here to like you
know see what's out there and also
demonstrate yourself as a a woman that a
man would want to be with and I think
just based off of that we got it was a
rocky road and I don't know if she
understood it to be as a rocky road
um and then you know she asked me
different questions I was like yeah
that's probably yeah when you eliminated
her she said I wasn't interested anyways
oh with the bird yeah that was a bit of
a burn you know a bit of a bit of a you
know but I was like I wish you well you
know yeah I think I'm gonna bring her
back I'm actually curious about the
conspiracy theory I'm I'm bringing her
back yeah yeah
okay so are you choosing yourself are
you choosing the lawyer who are we
foreign
like the math equations as I do
what's the next step we're going on a
date
um love love is the next step why would
choose myself as well a date on just
pearly things for a whopping 25 the
lawyer then come on lawyer let's let's
go get a papa we got 25 to spend come on
I'm gonna take it to Chuck E cheese I
will I don't know if you could I mean
the tokens are kind of pricey maybe try
a little yeah I mean with inflation the
way
maybe you know
okay so so
um the lawyer she's got no kids never
been married
seems like a successful you wanted a
talented lady she's already getting
blessing it out of the country uh-oh
yeah she's digital man she could we can
ride out together yeah you got to marry
that one to get blessing out of the
country uh oh she's gonna get you down
here bro fantastic all right well thank
you for watching everybody thank you for
participating we very much appreciate
you
taking the time to come down here and
vet some of these women you know as
women I think this shows that we really
need to improve yeah we really need to
be better because I can't keep giving
Pickens like this
I can't do it like I need someone with
no tattoos maybe less than you know how
many bodies less than give me
less than like you know seven bodies I
feel like would be decent depends on the
age if she's if she's 20 with seven
bodies she's a thought pocket
okay less than five bodies you know talk
about it less than five um
not too old under 30 and understands
men yes understands what men want
understands who men are it's very
important they are high Achievers so you
know DM me on Instagram if you'd like
to run pill Bachelor we'll see if other
promise the women will get better I will
improve ladies
what's up I'm right here I'm right here
what's up come shoot the shot and let go
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel and I will talk to you
next time and let's
thank you